مستمرون واياكم مشاهدينا في تغطيتنا
للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في السودان هدنه
هشه تبادل فيها طرفاء الصراع الاتهامات
بخرقها الدعم السريع يقول ان الجيش هاجم
قوته بمحيط القصر الجمهوري وارض المعسكره
وسوبا في وقت واحد فيما يقول الجيش ان
الدعم السريع يستخدم المدنيين دروعا بشريه
فيما رصد الجيش تحركات كثيفه لارتال
عسكريه من الدعم السريع تتجه من كردفان
ودارفور الى الخرطوم اهلا بكم الى تغطيه
حيه ومباشره على شاشه العربيه لليوم
الثاني عشر من الاحداث في السودان
احنا ما حنطلع من بيوتنا من بيوتنا ما
حنطلع أنموت في بيوتنا الموت واحد احنا
اولادنا نقوموا من الصباح عشان يجيبوا لنا
مويه لغايه بالليل مويه عشان نشرب نحن وين
حد وين يا حد وين يا حماتي يا اخي خافوا
الله فينا خافوا الله فينا لا حول ولا قوه
الا بالله
[موسيقى]
اذا لا تزال المواجهات مستمره حيث فشلت
الهدنه على ما يبدو في وقف اطلاق النار
بين الجيش والدعم السريع الاشتباكات تركزت
في العاصمه الخرطوم وتحديدا في محيط قصرها
الرئاسي ومناطق في محيط القياده العامه
واداره المرافق الاستراتيجيه التي تتعرض
لقصف مدفعي عشوائي وكذلك المناطق المحيطه
بمطار الخرطوم الدولي وحي المطار السكني
وفقا للجيش السوداني فان الاشتباكات
تتمركز ايضا في مناطق في بحري وام درمان
وفي هذه الاثناء تحدث الجيش السوداني
عن تحركات كثيفه لارسال عسكريه للدعم
السريع قادمه من كوردوفان ودافور لتعزيز
قوتها بالخرطوم كما اتهم الجيش ايضا قوات
الدعم السريع باستخدام المدنيين في
الاحياء السكنيه دروعا بشريه
فالمقابل حملت قوات الدعم السريع المجتمع
الدولي مسؤولياته تجاه خرق الهدنه من قبل
قيادات الجيش السوداني مشيره الى ان عدم
التزام قيادات الجيش بالهدنه تؤكد تعدد
مراكز القرار داخل الجيش كما اتهمت قوات
الدعم السريع قوات من الجيش بمهاجمه
مواقعها بمحيط القصر الجمهوري وارض
المعسكرات وسوبا في وقت واحد
هذا واظهرت صور استمرار اغلاق المجال او
المحال التجاريه في السودان مع تواصل
المواجهات المسلحه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع نشاهد
يعني عشره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في رئاسه الشرطه
رئاسه شرطه الولايه ودينا المواطنين
ماشيين ماشيين قال لهم يمشي فتحوا لهم
المخازن بتاعه شرطه المحليه
شرطه المحليه للمواطنين العاديين يمشوا
ياخذوا لهم اسلحه من شرطه المحليه لانه ما
في قوه يعني تحميم اي زول يمشي يحمي نفسه
وحول عمليات الاجلاء من السودان يشهد مطار
بورتسودان رحلات اجلاء بواقع ثلاثه رحلات
جويه يوميا على متنها مئات الرعايه من
الدول الاجنبيه والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
والموظفين الامويين هذا ووصلت احدى طائرات
الاجلاء الى بيروت بمساعده السعوديه محمله
باثنين وثلاثين شخصا كما تمر هذه العمليه
مشاهدينا الى ليبيا عبر ثلاث مراحل بريه
وجويه وبحريه تبدا بالانتقال بالحافله الى
بورتسودان ثم الى ميناء جده وصولا الى
المحطه الاخيره في طرابلس واستقبل مطار
معيتيجا الدولي 105 من افراد الجاليه
الليبيه في السودان بعد اجلائهم واكدت
الجزائر ان 13 فلسطينيا واثنين سوريا
وعددا اخرا من اعضاء سفرتهم بالخرطوم
قدموا من مطار
نبقى في بورتسودان وينضم الينا من هناك
مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار مرحبا بك
معي في هذا او في هذه التغطيه وفي هذا
البث المباشر بالصوره من بورت سودان كيف
تبدو الان عمليات الاجلاء لا زالت مستمره
من من بورتسودان من حولك
12 يوما مضت على تداعيات هذه الازمه ازمه
الاشتباكات والصراع المسلح بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
ما يحدث الان من تداعيات يبدو واضحا في
استمرار عمليات الاجلاء كما تتابعون الان
في هذه الصور المباشره القطعه البحريه
تاتي وتخرج تباعا من ميناء بورسودان هذه
احدى القطع البحريه التي تتبع للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وصل الصباح هذا اليوم
واقلت عدد من الجنسيات وعدم الرعايه الدول
بعد ان وصلوا في رحله شاقه من الخرطوم ومن
عدد من مدن السودان الى مدينه بورسودان
على ساحل البحر الاحمر هذه القطع البحريه
العسكريه تاتي اتباعا كما ذكرنا عدد من
الدول بعثت ممثليها الى هذه المدينه مدينه
بورسودان التي توجهت اليها الانظار انظار
المبعوثين والسفارات الدول
والرعايه الدول وحتى المواطنين السودانيين
الذين يرغبون في مغادره السودان وصلوا
بالالاف الى مدينه بورسودان هذه المدينه
الان مكتظه برعايه دول
بالاجانب بالسودانيين
الامور تمضي وفقه ما خطط له الجيش
السوداني الذي يشرف على عمليه الاجلاء بعد
التنسيق مع ممثلي البعثات الدبلوماسيه
والسفارات هنالك لجان تعمل على مدار 24
ساعه من اجل تسهيل اجلاء معظم من يرغب في
المغادره سواء كان من رعايه الدول العربيه
او الاوروبيه او الاسيويه او الافريقيه
الذين وصلوا خلال الايام الماضيه الى
مدينه بورسودان على ساحل البحر الاحمر
نضيف في اطار هذه التغطيه ايضا كنا قبل
قليل في مطار بورسودان الدولي هذا المطار
بدا عمليه التفويج منذ الثالث والعشرين من
هذا الشهر
وستستمر بحسب افادات مدير المطار وقيادات
عسكريه ستستمر هذه العمليه لان الطلبات ما
زالت تمضي وما زالت متواصله نحو الف شخص
يغادرون يوميا مطار بورسودان الدولي بواقع
ست الى ثمانيه رحلات يوميا تغادر مطار
بورسودان الدولي ايضا القطع البحريه تاتي
تباعا الطائرات العسكريه التي تصل الى
بورسودان تاتي تباعا وتنسق مع الجيش ومع
اداره المطار ومع الشرطه السودانيه حتى
تصل الى هذه المرحله مرحله تجلى الرعايه
الذين كما ذكرنا وصلوا بالمئات وحتى
بالالاف الى مدينه بورسودان بشرق السودان
فيما يخص المطار هل نتحدث عن طائرات
عسكريه تقل هؤلاء اللاجئين من الخرطوم ام
نتحدث عن طائرات تجاريه تصل الى مطار
بورتسودان وبعد ذلك
تنقل اللاجئين الى بلدانهم
السلطات السودانيه اعلنت بان ان المجال
الجوي السوداني مغلق بالكامل حتى الثلاثين
من هذا الشهر وحتى اشعار اخر امام حركه
الملاحه الجويه المدنيه للطائرات وللملاحه
لكن الذي او الطائرات التي تصل الى مدينه
بورسودان باعتبارها المدينه التي يوجد بها
المطار والقاعده الجويه الوحيده الان التي
تعمل على نقل المدنيين ونقل رعايه الدول
الطائرات التي تصل هي فقط من الطائرات
العسكريه التي تصل على مدى اليوم بواقع ست
طائرات الى سبع طائرات في اليوم هذه
الطائرات تاتي الى مطار بورسودان بعد
التنسيق مع الجيش والسلطات السودانيه تمضي
مباشره اما الى جيبوتي هنالك عدد من
القواعد واما تنتقل مباشره الى عدد من
الدول العربيه على سبيل المثال مصر
والسعوديه والاردن وتونس والمغرب وانقره
كل هذه المطارات هي تنسق الان مع مطار
بورسودان الدولي الذي يعمل على مدار
الساعه وهو المطار الوحيد الان بعد اغلاق
المجال الجوي السوداني الذي يعمل بتسهيلات
فنيه واداريه ولوجستيه وعدد من رعايه
الدول الان داخل صالات المغادره في مطار
بورسودان يستعدون لمغادره السودان عبر هذا
المنفذ الجوي الوحيد حتى الان المتاح
للمدنيين في السودان من يؤمن هذا المطار
النزار
هنالك لجنتان تم تشكيل هذه اللجان لجنتان
تم تشكيلهما من قبل الجيش ومن قبل السلطات
الامنيه هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر هنالك
لجنه امنيه تختص باجلاء المسافرين واجلاء
واجلاء الرعايه عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي
هذه اللجنه يشرف ويراس كل عملياتها ضابط
برتبه اللواء هنالك ايضا لجنه تختص
بالاجلاء البحري يتعلق بالتنسيق بين السفن
بين القطع البحريه بين ممثل السفارات
والبعثات هذه اللجنه ايضا برئاسه ضابط
رفيع في الجيش السوداني برتبه لواء بحري
هذه اللجان تعمل على تامين تامل تعمل على
تغطيه كل الاحتياجات الان مطار بورسودان
مؤمل بالكامل من قبل الجيش والوحدات
العسكريه وسلطات الامن هنا في شرق السودان
هنالك ايضا منطقه البحر الاحمر العسكريه
تشرف ايضا اشرافا كاملا على كل العمليات
الامنيه والاستخبار والتنسيق بين الممثلين
الذين وصلوا الى مدينه بورسودان الحديث عن
ممثلي عدد من السفارات وعدد من السفارات
ايضا بدات في نقل مكاتبها الى هذه المدينه
بغيت تسهيل اجراءات كافه الذين يرغبون في
مغادره السودان نضيف ايضا بان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هي من الجهات وهي من
الدول التي بدات تنسق خلال اليومين
الماضيين مع مختلف الدول في المنطقه سواء
كان دول عربيه او افريقيا او اسيويه او
حتى اوروبيه بهدف تسهيل مهام وصول الرعايه
والاجانب من الخرطوم الى هذه المدينه
وبعدها مباشره يغادرون عبر البحر الى
ميناء جده طيب انت ذكرت بان هناك الالاف
ممن يطلبون اللجوء موجودين الان في
بورتسودان اريد ان اسال هنا عن الوضع في
المدينه
يعني الوضع الانساني صحيا الوفره الغذائيه
فيما يخص المستشفيات والادويه ايضا كذلك
نزال
مدينه بورسودان هي مدينه ساحليه يعني حتى
تصبح الصوره عن مكان وعن ملامح هذه
المدينه هي مدينه ساحليه تطل على البحر
الاحمر توصف بعروس البحر الاحمر هنا في
السودان ياتي اليها السياح في مختلف
المناطق وحتى في السودان هي قبل سياحيه
هذه المدينه مهيئه بالفنادق بالشقق
السكنيه بالدور الايوائيه
لاحظنا بان هنالك ضغطا على الشقق السكنيه
على المساكن على الفنادق حتى ان بعض
الجاليات وقبل ان تغادر العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم تجري الاتصالات المكثفه بهدف
تامين مكان للمبيت وحتى تستطيع ان تكمل
الاجراءات المتعلقه بالجوازات والهجره
والوثائق الثبوتيه وبعدها تغادر عبر ميناء
بورسودان الى جده او الى اي وجهه اخرى
الاوضاع الان هنا مستقره في هذه المدينه
السلطات الامنيه والصحيه تعمل على
مدى 24 ساعه لتامين احتياجات الرعايه
الدول الاجنبيه السوق التجاري الان منتعش
بحكم وجود مئات من رعايه الدول وصلوا الى
هذه المدينه المستشفيات تعمل بطاقتها
الكليه لم نلحظ او نسجل اي امراض او اي
اعراض صحيه يعني اصابه الذين وصلوا الى
هذه المدينه والى هذه المنطقه من شرق
السودان الامور هنا مستقره في شرق السودان
لجنه امن ولايه البحر الاحمر برئاسه
الوالي وبرئاسه القيادات العسكريه
والامنيه والشراطيه تقول بانها تؤمن كافه
المجالات وكافه المسارات الانسانيه
والخدميه والامنيه وحتى تمضي هذه العمليه
الكبرى عمليه الاجلاء الكبرى في السودان
لكل من يريد ان يغادر السودان في ظروف
صحيه وانسانيه وامنيه ملائمه تمكنهم من
اكمال هذه العمليه اشكرك شكر جزيلا على
هذه الصوره والمعلومات التي نقلتها لنا من
مدينه
بورتسودان مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي شكرا
جزيلا لك
من جانبه عبرت بريطانيا عن قلقها ازاء
التقارير التي تفيد بان الطرفين اخفق مره
اخرى بالوفاء في التزاماتهما حول الهدنه
وادعت قوات الجيش والدعم السريع الى وقف
دائما لاطلاق النار وانهاء العنف بالاضافه
الى السماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه
وضمان حمايه مدنيين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني والطبي
من جانبه دع الامين العامه للامم المتحده
انطونيو كوتيريوس دعا الاطراف المتصارعه
في السودان الى وقف القتال في البلاد
مشددا على ان القتال لن يكون حلا للصراع
بين القوتين
دعا قاده السودان لجعل مصالح شعبهم اولويه
وان يقوموا باسكات اسلحتهم فورا
عربت الخارجيه الالمانيه في بيان عن
ترحيبها باتفاق وقف اطلاق النار بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لمده ثلاثه
ايام اشاره الوزاره الى ان السودانيين
بحاجه لوقف اطلاق النار بشكل دائم لتفادي
اي عنف والسماح بوصول المساعدات
والامدادات الطبيه مؤكده انها تبذل كل ما
بوسعها من خلال جميع القنوات الدبلوماسيه
لوقف اطلاق النار في البلاد وايدت
الخارجيه الالمانيه انشاء لجنه لوضع حد
دائم للقتال في السودان والعمل على تنسيق
المساعدات في البلاد
من بيروت ينضم الينا المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الاتحاد الاوروبي في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا لويس ميغيل بوينو مرحبا بك سيد
لويس معي في هذه التغطيه على شاشه العربيه
اريد ان اسال اولا عن موقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي مما حدث في الهدنه بالسودان هدنه
وصفت بان هشه تم اختراقها من قبل الطرفين
في اكثر من مناسبه
اولا شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه وتحيه لك
للمشاهدين الكرام نحن كنا نرحب بطبيعه
الحال باعلان هذه الهدنه الانسانيه في
السودان بعد ايام من من الصراع ولكن صحيح
هناك اعلانات هنا هناك لاختراقات
وانتحاكات لكن نحن نريد ان نكرر دعواتنا
لنطاق المتقاتله
لجعل هذه الهدنه الانسانيه لوقت لقد نار
دائم هذا هو المطلوب وكما تفضلت في تقريرك
هذه الدعوه يعني اتت لسودانيين وتم
اعلانها يعني من قبل الاطراف مختلفه سواء
كان لسعيد الدولي وسعيد الاقليمي فالمخطوط
الان نوقف بشكل دايم ولا دوله المفوضات
هذا هو الموقف الاوروبي ونحن قلنا مباشر
المتقاتله في هذا الاطار يعني انت تؤكد
الان انكم تواصلتم مع طرفي النزاع مع
البرهان ومع حميتي
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي اتصل
بالاثنين الجدرلين في هذا الاطار في اثاره
جهود الراميه من قبل الاتحاد وايضا من قبل
شركائنا الدوليين
من اجل الواقف اللقب وذلك ايضا في اطار
يعني جهودنا من خلال البعثه الدبلوماسيه
اللي كانت في في موجوده في الخرطوم بتربيه
الحلا الان تم نقل الموظفين الاوروبيين
خارج السودان ولكن هذه جهود مستمره من
خلال المبعوث الخاصه لهذا المنطقه
اليوم الجلسات في الاتحاد الافريقي
والتقم الرئيس المفوض الى تركيا في هذا في
هذا السبب طيب هل الاتحاد الاوروبي في هذه
الازمه على مساحه وعلى مسافه واحده من
طرفي النزاع في السودان
الاجراءاتها ببذل الجهود اللازمه من اجل
وقف اللق النار لكن على ما يبدو الطرفان
يتماسكان
بموقفهما في هذه الاوقات ومره اخرى هذه
الدعوه مفتوحه ومستمره للطرفان لوقف
القتال نعرف انه هذه يعني هذه الظروف صعبه
للجميع ولكن لا يوجد اي بديل لشوار في هذه
في هذه الحاله طيب ما الذي يخشاه الاتحاد
الاوروبي اليوم من تفجر الاوضاع في
السودان والتصاعد وتيره الاحتراب بين طرفي
الازمه
نعم يعني كان كابل هذه الاسماء كان يعاني
يا سودان من اسمى انسانيه مجريه يعني سيل
للغايه كان الاوضاع ولا يزال للاسف شديد
للغايه في المناطق السودانيه نتحدث 14
مليون نسمه الذين يعانون ويعتمدون بشكل
وبياخر على المساعده الانسانيه فبالتالي
هناك تضعيات واضحه للسيده الانساني كما
راينا خلال الايام الماضيه هناك
كذلك يعني اعتقد انه الدول المجاوره خصوصا
ستكون اكثر تضررا من الاتحاد الاوروبي في
هذا المجال فعبرنا عن قلقنا بطبيعه الحال
يعني ازاحه التطورات يعني فيما يتعلق
بتضايات وانكاسات هذه
الاحاطه الصراعها في المنطقه وخارج منطقه
كذلك
مخاوف اوروبيه بالفعل هل تم اجزاء كل
بعثتكم من السودان مواطني حتى دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي بامان
نعم تم نقلاء الموظفين الاوروبيين اللي
كان شغالين يعني في مكتبنا في الخرطوم
بالاضافه الى
1200 تقريبا مواطن اوروبي من جميع
الجنسيات في الاتحاد خلال يومين قبل يومين
وخلال الويكند الماضي الان هناك قليل جدا
من الروبين
البقيه في كم تبقى تقريبا من اعداد
الاوروبيين الموجودين في السودان كنا
نتحدث قبل هذه الاسماء تقريبا عن 1700
مواطن الان تم اجراء تقريبا
1200 فالبقيه هي تقريبا 500
هل هناك تقديرات لموعد اجلائهم من السودان
هل سيتجهون مباشره الى
جده ومن هناك ايضا الى دولهم ام سيكون الى
احدى القواعد العسكريه الاوروبيه الموجوده
في الدول المجاوره للسودان لا الان هذه
العمليه الاسلام مستمره كما تعلمون
فبالتالي يعني هناك من قبل السفرات
للدول المجاوره ايضا
للمفاضل الاوروبيه لها
يعني اجتماع تقريبا يومي لتنسيق لتنسيق
هذا الموضوع او ننسك الموضوع بعد ولا هناك
طرق مختلفه
للخروج من السودان الان طبعا ليس ساحلا
ولكن ليس مستحيلا ايضا فبالتالي نحن ننسق
ذلك مع فرنسا مع جيبوتي على فكره دور محب
جدا في هذه العمليه عمليه الاسلام
ونستمر بتنسيق ذلك ولكن المهمه الان طبعا
السودانيين انفسهم وحمايه السوداني
نتحدث عن يعني السودانيين الذين في نهايه
المط يدفعون اخل ثمن وهذا هو هو السؤال عن
عن ما بعد اجلاء البعثه الدبلوماسيه لكم
ما بعد اجل ايضا حتى الرعايه الاوروبيه من
السودان والغربيين بشكل عام ماذا بعد
عمليات الاجلاء ما الذي تتوقعونه في
السودان سيد لويس نعم هذه النقطه لغايه
العاميه وشارع اليها الممثل على نفسه خلال
تصريحته قبل يومين نريد ان نقول بان قبل
يعني بعد عمليه الاشلاء سنترك السودانيين
ورائنا كما كما نقول بين القوسين صحيح انه
الظروف الحاليه صعبه ولا يمكننا ان نقوم
باعمالنا كالعاده تم اعتدال صفيرنا تم
اعتداء الام مسؤول المكتب الانساني في
السودان كذلك في الاتحاد الاوروبي
فبالتالي في هذه الظروف الصعب ان نعمل
بواجبنا ولكن رغم كذا كل ذلك نكون الوضع
بتنسيق المتحده لمواصله تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه
الملزمه لللازمه عفوا للمحتاجين ليس فقط
في الخرطوم وايضا في مناطق اخرى وهناك
نيه واضحه من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي في هذا
السبب هل تبين لديكم اخيرا سيد لويس من
اعتدى على بعثتكم الدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم
عفوا هل تبين لديكم من اعتدى على موظفيكم
موظفي الاتحاد الاوروبي في ومكتبكم في
الخرطوم لا لا يكون واضح من المسؤول عن
ذلك
ليس لدينا معطياتها لهذا الموضوع وتم نقل
كل موظفين
طبعا الان البيت الابيض يؤكد مقتل
امريكي الثاني في السودان
البيت الابيض اذا الان كما نشاهد اسفل
الشاشه يؤكد مقتل امريكي ثاني في السودان
جراء هذه الاحداث المتصاعده
والتوترات اذا في السودان والتي تجري منذ
اثني عشر
يوما ويقول بان مستوى العنف بالسودان
تراجع خلال الهدنه ونريد الانتقال الى
حكومه بدنيه هذا مجمل ما قاله البيت
الابيض على كل حال شكرا جزيلا للسيد لويس
مي
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
مباشره الى هذه الصور المباشره
لعمليات الاجلاء التي تقوم بها الحكومه
البريطانيه لمواطنيها الذين كانوا يقطنون
العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وبقيه طبعا المدن
السودانيه اذا هذه صور شاهدناها واياكم لا
زلنا الان على شاشه العربيه ننوه الى انها
صور لوصول رعايه بريطانيين الى بريطانيا
بعد ان تم اجلائهم من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم
رصدت العربيه مشاهدينا وصول اول طائره
اجلاء مغربيه من السودان الى مطار محمد
الخامس الدولي في مدينه الدار البيضاء
وكان على متن الطائره السلك الدبلوماسي
المغربي وافراد من الجاليه المغربيه
المقيمه في السودان والذين وصل عددهم الى
نحو 130 شخصا
البري الفاصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه اما للفارين من الفارينه من
اشتباكات السودان خصوصا من مدينتي الخرطوم
وام درمان القريبتين وعلى مدار الاسبوعين
الماضيين يصل الاف من المصريين
والسودانيين ورعايه من جنسيه اخرى
الكثيرون تحدثوا عن خطوره الاوضاع وعن
صعوبه الرحله من السودان وصولا للحدود
المصريه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان مع
التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اخر نقطه الحدوديه لعبور المصريين
والسودانيين والرعايه الاجانب الذين
يهربون من جحيم ما يحدث في السودان الى
مصر
الضرب
والقف الخرطوم وضرب بيجا عشوائي بقى الضرب
يعني
حدث ولا حرج
ة لحد ما وصلنا القاهره في امان الله
[موسيقى]
شديد
وضحايا شديد
والغنابل بتقع في خشم الباب
ونهب مسلح بصوره عشوائيه احنا دلوقتي جينا
وبيوتنا مش معروف عن القهوه
[موسيقى]
خلال هذه الحافلات سينتقلون الى وجهتهم
المقبله مدينه اسوان التي تبعد عن هذا
المنفذ حدودي 500 كلم
[موسيقى]
نبقى مع زميل احمد عثمان مباشره من معبر
ارجين على الحدود المصريه السودانيه احمد
مرحبا بك معي من جديد في هذه التغطيه
المتواصله للاحداث في السودان من خلفك
نشاهد حافلات ربما تحمل يعني امتعه
وتتوجه باتجاه الحدود المصريه والى داخل
الحدود المصريه كيف هي الصوره من حولك
بالفعل كما ذكرت يعني الحافلات في كل مكان
هناك حافلات التي يعني هنا في انتظار خروج
المصريين والسودانيين الذين يخرجون من
المعبر تباعا لنقلهم الى وجهتهم المختلفه
كما تحدثنا كثيرا قبل ذلك الوجهه الرئيسيه
هي مدينه اسوان التي تبعد حوالي 400 كيلو
متر يعني الان ربما الشكوى الرئيسيه من
قبل الكثيرين هي طول فتره الانتقالات ما
بين الجانب السوداني الى الجانب المصري
هذه النقطه تحديدا يعني يتحدث فيها البعض
بان هذا التدفق الكبير في الذين ياتون من
السودان الى مصر خلال الايام الماضيه منذ
اندلاع الاحداث ردت علي هيئه الموانئ
المصريه من خلال بيان اكدت فيه بانه سيكون
هناك ربما
تشكيل لموظفين اضافيين لمراعاه هذه
المشكله
تسهيل مهمه دخول السودانيين والمصريين
فيما
بهذه النقطه النقطه الاخرى التي ايضا
اثارت نوع من اللغط خلال الايام والساعات
الاخيره المتعلقه بالتاشيرات يعني كان
هناك بعض القوانين التي تحد عمليه انتقال
المصريين الى السودان والسودانيين الى مصر
وفق ما كان يعرف بقانون الحريات الاربعه
هذا القانون تم تعديله في عام 2017 واثيره
هناك بعض اللغط حول هذه الشروط وتطبيقها
في ظل هذه الظروف بحسب ما علمناه بان هذه
النقطه تحديدا يتم تداركها من خلال
البيانات التي اصدرتها وزاره الخارجيه
المصريه حول الدروع ان يكون هناك تاشيره
من احد القنصليات او مكاتب العمل والتي
كان اقربها وادي حلفا هناك بعض الشروط
والاستثناءات المتعلقه تحديدا بكبار السن
او من هم فوق الخمسين عاما الذين يتم
خروجهم بشكل مباشر اعاد ذلك هناك استمرار
لتوفير وتسهيل كافه التسهيلات الممكنه من
قبل السلطات المصريه للقادمين من السودان
هناك مركز اغاثه هناك مجموعه من سيارات
الاسعاف والاطباء للتعامل الطبي مع اي نوع
من الاصابات او الارهاق الى غير ذلك وكما
يعني تحدثنا يعني هناك الجميع يتفق ويشارك
فيه يعني التعبير عن الحزن والقلق والغضب
والخوف عن ما هو قادم فيما يتعلق بالسودان
كيف يسوقون المشهد المستقبلي في السودان
المشهد السياسي المشهد الامني هل ستكون
اقامتهم في مصر هي مؤقتا لمده ايام هل
سيتجهون الى اسوان لفتره قصيره ثم يعودون
هل يتجهون الى القاهره هناك حاله بالتاكيد
من التخبط تسيطر على الجميع والتامل
والتامل لمستقبل المشهد السياسي والامني
وفي السودان وامكانيه عوده هؤلاء مره اخرى
الى بلادهم في ظل الظروف الراهنه طيب اسال
كذلك عن الكثافه احمد يعني كثافه
الواصلين الى هذا المعبر هل تزيد يوما بعد
اخر ام تقل بسبب عمليات الاجلاء يعني التي
كانت على قدم وساق خلال الايام الماضيه
اتحدث عن الارقام هناك معبرين
حدوديين بريين لتجمعان ما بين مصر
والسودان هذا المعبر الاول هو معبر ارجين
خلال الساعات او الايام الماضيه تم
الاعلان عن اكثر من 700,700 شخص تم عبورهم
من هذا المعبر في المعبر الاخر وهو معبر
خاصه تم الاعلان عن في حدود 1300 هناك
تحديث رسمي من قبل السلطات المصريه فيما
يتعلق باعداد من يدخلون من المعابر البريه
وايضا على الجانب الاخر تقوم السلطات
المصريه بارسال طائرات عسكريه تقريبا
طائرتين في كل يوم لنقل العالقين المصريين
في الخرطوم تحديدا يتم نقلهما عدد من
المصريين الذين ربما يجدون صعوبه في
التحرك كل هذه المسافه من الخرطوم الى هذه
المنطقه يتم نقلهم عن طريق طائرات عسكريه
مصريه تحط في مدينه الخرطوم بشكل يومي
وايضا هناك تحديث يومي من قبل وزاره
الخارجيه المصريه حول الاعداد هل ستزيد
الاعداد ام تقل هناك من يرى بان ربما هذه
هي زور الايام يومين الماضيين وعدم
والايام المقبله ستشهد ذروه الوصول وهذا
اعتمادا على ما قد يحدث في الخرطوم هل
سيكون هناك المزيد من العنف مما يدفع
الكثير للتوجه الى دول الجوار ومن بينها
مصر ام ان جهود الجهود الدوليه والاقليميه
للوصول الى مجموعه من الهدن حتى ولو هشه
قد ربما تقلل من عمليات النزوح الكبير الى
الحدود المصريه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من معبر
اركين على الحدود المصريه السودانيه مراسل
العربيه احمد عثمان
نذكر مشاهدينا بهذه الاخبار العاجله البيت
الابيض يؤكد مقتل امريكيين ثاني في
السودان ويؤكد بان وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان مستمر رغم بعض الخروقات البيت
الابيض يقول بانه يحاول تامين خروج كل
امريكي يريد مغادره السودان وبان مستوى
العنف بالسودان تراجع خلال الهدنه ونريد
الانتقال الى حكومه مدنيه هذا مجمل ما جاء
في تصريح البيت الابيض نعيده فقط للتذكير
لمشاهدينا ومستمعينا مستوى العنف بالسودان
تراجع خلال الهدنه ونريد الانتقال الى
حكومه مدنيه البيت الابيض يتحدث مقتل
امريكي ثاني في السودان ويقول بانه يحاول
تامين خروج كل امريكي يريد مغادره السودان
ووقف اطلاق النار في السودان مستمر رغم
بعض الخروقات وقال بانه يعمل مع كلا طرفي
الصراع في السودان
لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار هذا مجمل ما جاء
في بيان البيت الابيض
نشاهد هذه الصور ايضا المباشره مشاهدينا
لوصول اول طائره قادمه من السودان تحمل
مواطنين بريطانيين كما نشاهد الان امامنا
اذا وصلت اول طائره قادمه من السودان تحمل
مواطنين
بريطانيين كانت قد اجلتهم الحكومه
البريطانيه بعد التوترات وبعد النزاع بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
السودان منذ 12 يوما بدات الكثير من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي
باجلاء بعثاتها الدبلوماسيه ورعاياها
الموجودين في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
الان نشاهد هذه الصور المباشره
لطائره بريطانيه حطت في مطار لندن
كما نشاهد امامنا الان مطار لندن
ستانستيد الان هذه الطائره التي وصلت وتقل
رعايه بريطانيين على ما يبدو كانوا علامات
هذه الطائره التي وصلت الى بريطانيا اذا
الى مطار لندن ستانسد في هذه الصور
المباشره امامنا على شاشه العربيه للطائره
التي قدمت من السودان لا زالت عمليات
الاجلاء يعني قائمه على قدم وساق من
السودان اجلاب عفاف دبلوماسيه ورعايه
ومواطنين ايضا كذلك لدول اجنبيه كانت
موجوده في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم عبر
البر الى مصر كما شاهدنا قبل قليل عبر
معبرغين وكذلك ايضا عبر
البحر من ميناء بورتسودان منه الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تحديدا الى جده والتي
استقبلت الالاف من
رعايه الدول والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
والاماميه ايضا وربما اذا كذلك جوا من
مطار بورتسودان العسكري او المطارات
العسكريه والقواعد العسكريه للدول
المجاوره للسودان
رصاص الدوشكا الروسي كان ينطلق من داخل
المنازل يخترق الجدران يصيب السكان
باصابات بالغه هذا ما نقله احد الطلاب
المصريين العائدين من السودان للعربيه
نشاهد
رشاش الدوشكا الروسي صمم في الثلاثينات من
القرن الماضي
السودان من الدول التي تستخدم هذا الرشاش
بكثره
طلقته كبيره الحجم من عيار 12.7 ملم
يصل مدرا الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه متر
[تصفيق]
في الاصل هو رشاش ثقيل مضاد للطائرات
يمكن استخدامه ضد المدرعات الخفيفه
والاليات العسكريه
اذا تم استخدامه في المناطق المدنيه سيؤدي
الى اضرار مروعه
شهدت الحدود التشاديه السودانيه وصول
حوالي 20 لاجئ سوداني منذ اندلاع الحرب في
السودان او 20 الف لاجئ سوداني منذ ذراع
الحرب في السودان
ورصدت مشاهد في تشاد للاوضاع الانسانيه
الصعبه التي يعيشها السودانيون مع لجوء
عدد كبير من النساء والاطفال وسط انعدام
ابسط مقومات الحياه
[موسيقى]
وحول جهود السعوديه بشان المساهمه في
اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب عبر موانئ جده
بالبحر الاحمر وصلت الفرقاطه الفرنسيه
لورين الى جده وعلى متنها اكثر من 400 شخص
قادمين من السوداني هربا من الاقتتال
الدائر في هذا السياق اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه ان سفينه تقل الف
وستمائه وسبعه مدنيا من اكثر من خمسين
دوله فروا من العنف في السودان قد وصلت
بالفعل الى السعوديه الاربعاء في اكبر
عمليه انقاذ من نوعها تنفذها المملكه حتى
الان وزاره الخارجيه وفي بيان الله اكدت
حرصا المملكه على توفير كامل الاحتياجات
الاساسيه للرعايه الاجانب تمهيدا لتسهيل
مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم
الان بدا نزول
الاشخاص على متن او رعايه بعثه الامم
المتحده ونشاهد ايضا هذه السيده والتي
ترافقها احدى المجندات السعوديات من الحرس
من حرس الحدود وكذلك جود من حرس الحدود
يرافقونها في عمليه نزولهم وهي من الدفعه
الاولى طبعا الفئات المخصصه للاحتياجات
الطبيه هم يقومون به الان النزول والمتوجه
مباشره الى مركبه الاسعاف كما نشاهد التي
خصصتها الصحه وهيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي
وكذلك السلطات السعوديه وتامين صحه وسلامه
رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده تحمل هذه
الفرقاطه قرابه 400 شخص من جنسيات مختلفه
هناك السلك الدبلوماسي لعدد من الدول سواء
الدول من اوروبا وكذلك امريكا وهم ايضا
سوف يستقبلون بعض رعاياهم من بعثه الامم
المتحده يتواجدون الان هنا على رصيف ميناء
جده الاسلامي هنا ايضا وصول او نزول ايضا
المزيد من بعثه الامم المتحده ورعايته
الامم المتحده الذين وصلوا للتو الان
ساهمت سفينه وامان السعوديه باجلاء مئات
الاشخاص من مختلف الجنسيات العالم مسجله
بذلك اكبر عمليه اجلاء من السودان حتى
الان نتعرف سويا على هذه السفينه
سفينه امان السعوديه تقوم باكبر عمليه
اجلاء من السودان السفينه ترفع علم
السعوديه منذ 44 عاما
ايطاليه الصنع تملكها شركه نماء للتجاره
الدوليه عرضها يصل الى 23 مترا وطولها ل
مئات الرعايه الاجانب استخدموها لتنقلهم
من ميناء سواكن الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده يصلون لوجهتهم المستقره
وتغمرهم فرحه النجاه يلوحون لها شكرا
امانه على الامانه
من احد مقرات ايواء ركاب رحلات الاجلاء من
السودان في جده يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه
عن نصفيان هاني مرحبا بك معي الصوره معك
كيف تبدو ما الذي رصدته رصدته في هذا
المقر هاني
نايف اهلا بك مره اخرى واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه في موقع اخر وموقع مختلف وتحديدا
في احد المقرات التي هياتها السعوديه
ووفرتها من اجل الرعايه الجنسيات المختلفه
بعد عمليه الاجراء التي قامت بها سواء عبر
سفنيها او كذلك عبر الفرقه الفرنسيه هنا
في احد الفنادق الخمس التي خصصتها
السعوديه وايضا الامر متاح في زياده هذه
الاعداد المقرات في حاله زياده اعداد
الرعايه الذين من الممكن ان يزداد عددهم
خلال الفتره المقبله طبعا لعل صوره هنا قد
تكون اكثر الرفاهيه
بخلاف الاعداد التي قد نشاهدها لان اغلب
الرعايه الذين وصلوا من الجنسيات المختلفه
قاموا بالدخول فورا الى غرفهم لانهم كانوا
على رحله مضت قرابه العشر ساعات وايضا
كانت عن طريق البحر كما شاهدنا ايضا
كاميرا العربيه فيها النشرات الماضيه ولكن
كنا نرغب هنا في هذه هذا المقر تحديدا ان
نرصد العمليات او التجهيزات التي خصصتها
السعوديه داخل هذا المقر كيف هي
الغرف ايضا عمليه تجهيز الوجبات ايضا
عمليه تجهيز الفندق هذا الفندق تحديدا
كباقي الفنادق الاخرى هو بفئه خمسه نجوم
هو مهيا هناك عدد من موظفين في الاسفل عند
الاستقبال هم مخصصين فقط من اجل تلبيه
احتياجات وتوفير مستلزمات ما يرغبه
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا بلدانهم عبر مطار
الملك عبد العزيز
[موسيقى]
او ايضا وصلوا يوم امس غادروا مباشره الى
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي اليوم نتحدث
عن قرابه المئه وخمسين شخص من هؤلاء
الرعايه غادروا مباشره عمليه ايضا
مغادرتهم خلال الساعات القادمه هي مستمره
وسوف ايضا نقوم برصدها في النشرات القادمه
هنا فقط كنا نرصد الصوره ونرصد ايضا
المقرات وكنا نتوقع ايضا ان تكون عمليات
المقرات هي في
نظام العماير او البنايات الكامله
بغرف مقسمه ولكن
اصبحت هذه المقرات هي مقرات لفنادق من فئه
خمسه نجوم
ونحن الان نرصدها عبر شاشه العربيه سواء
من خلال الغرف او من خلال الباحات او
المساحات الموجوده طبعا جميع الغرف هنا لا
استطيع رفع الصوت اكثر من اللازم لان جميع
الذين وصلوا هم يسكنون في هذه الغرف سوى
هذه الغرفه التي دخلناها قبل قليل وكان قد
غادرها احد الجنسيات المغادره الى نيروبي
وقد غدر الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
في مدينه جده وبعد ذلك تم نقله او تم نقله
ايضا عبر حافله مخصصه مع ضمن عدد من
الجنسيات التي غادرت طبعا هذه هنا ايضا في
هذه الساحه او في ساحه اللوبي ايضا او
ساحه عند الاستقبال هي جلسه للذين يمضون
فيها عدد من الجاليات التي وصلته نشاهد
ايضا عمليه جلوسهم والاماكن والمكان
المتاح للجلوس عند رغبتهم في الجلوس خارج
غرفهم طبعا ايضا هناك عدد من
الموظفين السفارات الذين وصلوا لرعايه
هؤلاء الجنسيات هم ايضا لهم مكاتب وخاصه
ولهم ايضا
تواصل بشكل مباشر مع السلطات السعوديه
لعمليات الترتيب لمغادره رعاياهم الى
بلدانهم ووجهتهم الاخيره اشكرك شكر جزيل
على هذه المعلومات على الصوره التي نقلتها
لنا من احد مقرات ايواء ركاب رحلات
الاجزاء من السودان في جده مراسل العربيه
نصفين شكرا جزيلا لهاني
اذا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه
انها انتهت من عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
مضيحه انها اكملت اجلاء نقلت خلاله اكثر
من 700 شخص الى خارج السودان بينهم 200
مواطن الماني
ونعود مره اخرى لمتابعه هذه الصور
المباشره الى خبر وصول اول طائره قادمه من
السودان الى بريطانيا تحمل مواطنين
بريطانيين وينضم الينا من لندن المراسل
العربيه مصطفى زورو مصطفى مرحبا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه ماذا لديك من معلومات
سنتناولها بعد قليل معك مصطفى بعد ان يصبح
هذا الاتصال جاهزا
سنعود بعده الى الزميل مصطفى زارو ليطلعنا
طبعا على
وصول هذه الطائره البريطانيه الى مطار
لندن كنا قد تابعنا قبل قليل الوصولها الى
بريطانيا واجلائها ايضا لبعض الرعايه
البريطانيين وبعض الدول الصديقه لبريطانيا
من السودان اذا مشاهدينا قال مسؤول في
البحريه الامريكيه لشبكه سي ان ان
الولايات المتحده سترسل سفينه حربيه ثالثه
الى السودان تمت بسرعه عاليه نسبيا وذلك
بعد يوم واحد فقط من اعلان وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه عن وصول سفينه للسواحل
السودانيه وتوجه اخرى من بحر العرب الى
هناك اضاف المسؤول البحري ان السفن الثلاث
قادره على نقل مئات الاطنان من المعدات
وعدد كبير من الافراد بسرعات عاليه نسبيا
الى بريطانيا مراسل العربيه من لندن مصطفى
زارو مصطفى مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
ماذا لديك من تفاصيل حول هذه الطائره التي
حطت قبل قليل وتحمل رعايه بريطانيين تم
اجلائهم من السودان
وزاره الدفاع التي على عمليه النقل او
اجنا
وصاحب الجنسيه المزدوجه الى المملكه
المتحده بعدما كانت هناك يعني رحله تقريبا
ممثله عبر
علمتني عسكريه من من قاعده عسكريه في
ضواحي السودان باتجاه قبرص ومن هناك من
لارمكه تم تاجير الطائره خاصه لنقل هؤلاء
انا حاليا انا اتواجد في في مطار
لم اشاهد بعض هؤلاء الذين تم اجلائهم ربما
لاستكمال كثره الاجراءات
التدقيق في الجمارك ومن ثم الخروج ولربما
حتى استخدام
مخارج اخرى خاصه بان هذه الطائره
في
ليست يعني ال ال او المدرج ليست ليس مدرج
الذي يتم استخدامه من قبل الطائرات
للمشاهدين ولكن هذه في صاله خاصه ننتظر
اذا ما كان هؤلاء سيخرجون من المطار من من
مدخله الرئيسي لكن بالطبع الكل كان ينتظر
هذه الرحله الاولى حتى هذه اللحظه اكدت
اكد مقهر رئاسه الوزراء ان تمشاء
311 تقريبا من هؤلاء الذين كانوا محاصرين
في السودان وبالطبع هذا عدد قليل مقارنه
بما بالتقديرات التي تشير الى ما يقارب من
4000 بريطانيه يعني متواجدون حاليا ان
هناك بالطبع من دون العوده الى المملكه
المتحده لاسلام وظروف شخصيه ولكن
نتوقع ان تكون هناك ثلاث على الاقل ثلاث
رحلات من من قبرص الى المملكه المتحده في
هذا مصطفى انا اشكرك جزيلا شكر على كل هذه
المعلومات سنتابع معك طبعا في سياق
تغطيتنا ونشرتنا القادمه توفرت لديك
معلومات اكثر وربما صوره اقرب وادق
للواصلين الى بريطانيا من اللاجئين
البريطانيين وبعض الدول الى بريطانيا شكرا
جزيلا لك والى تداعيات هروب عدد من رموز
النظام السابق من سجن كوبر بالعاصمه
الخرطوم فقد اكد الجيش السوداني ان الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير لا يزال محتجزا بمستشفى
عسكري تحت حراسه الشرطه القضائيه الجيش
قال في بيان له ان البشير وعدد من قيادات
حزبه محتجزون في مستشفى علي العسكري الجيش
عبر عن رفضه لاي محاولات لربط ما يجري في
السجون بمزايدات على مواقفه الوطنيه وصف
الجيش السوداني الدعم السريع وقائده بانهم
امتداد للنظام السابق
الحديث عن سجن كوبر الذي غادرت منه
قياداته من نظام البشير ابرزهم احمد هارون
فهذا السجن يقع في بحري بالعاصمه الخرطوم
ويبعد عن المستشفى العسكري نحو 10
كيلومترات اي حوالي سبعه عشره دقيقه
بالسياره وبحسب الجيش
السوداني فان الرئيس السابق يركض في
المستشفى العسكري تحت رقابه امنيه قبل
اندلاع الاشتباكات
ومعي هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني محمود لعوته السيد محمود مرحبا
بك معي في هذه التغطيه على شاشه العربيه
هناك هدنه في السودان توصف بان هدنه هشه
تخترق من كل جانب ولكن يعني لربما البيت
الابيض قبل قليل يعني اكد بان وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان مستمر رغما بعض هذه
الخروقات على الجانب الاخر هنالك مساله
تبدو حاسمه للطرفين بمحاوله السيطره على
هذا السباق النوعي فيما يخص مطار الخرطوم
فيما يخص ايضا كذلك القياده العامه مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون على الارض ما هو الوضع
اين نحن
طبعا
بالنسبه
من خلال ال 12 يوم اللي تابعناها يعني في
نقطه مهمه جدا يعني اول حاجه لابد ان افهم
انه في الفتره السابقه
الدعم السريع يستعان بكثير من خبرات
طوبات وجنود القوات المسلحه بالذات الذين
يعني تم الاستغناء عنهم او الذين يعني تم
اعطائهم المعاش
يعني يستفاد منهم كثير يعني في في في في
في في في تعزيز او تدريب الجنود
العشوائيين الذي استعن بهم
نلاحظ انه وقت الدعم السريع في الفتره
الاخيره انتشرت في الاسواق وفي الازقه وفي
الشوارع الرئيسيه كما يقال يعني الان مثلا
في فتره قالوا انه احتلينا شارع مدني يعني
يمكن كل الشوارع الرئيسيه اللي تؤدي الى
العاصمه الخرطوم اعتقد هم منتشرين فيها
باستخدام الاسلحه الخفيفه اللي تستطيع انه
يتحركوا معها يعني فبالتالي يعني ما ما
بكون في يعني تكافؤ في المساله
وبنلاحظ انه اللي بحاول الجيش ان يحسم
المساله المساله المعركه باستخدام الطيران
لكن لا نستطيع لو حتى الصواريخ نوعيه لكن
لم يستطيع لانه هذه المواقع فيها سكان
وفيها مدنيين فمن الصعب يعني يعني يستخدم
هذا الاسلوب فترجع انه ما اعتقد انهم
تكتيكات الان يمكن في قوات مشاهده دخلت من
بعض الحاميات او القوات من الاقاليم قد
تساعد الجيش لحسم المساله لكن في الوقت
الراهن ليس هنالك كاسب كما
الممثل الامم المتحده يعني يعتقد كله من
الطرفان انه سوف يحسم المساله عسكريا لكن
لا يستطيع هناك سؤال مهم سيد محمود ان كسب
احد طرفي هذه
الازمه انكسب يعني السيطره على الخرطوم
فهل هناك ما يمنع لان تنتقل هذه الحرب الى
مناطق اقاليم سودانيه اخرى وارد جدا يعني
انا ممكن اذكر لك الان
الاشتباكات مشتده في الفاشر او في مناطق
عده في دارفور وهي منطقه النزاع الرئيسي
اللي فيها الحركات المسلحه واللي فيها بدا
حمايه تيئه محاربه الحركات المسلحه في
فتره نظام البشير البشريه يعني انا اعتقد
يمكنك الجيش السوداني قال احنا ضربنا بعض
القوات القادمه من كردفان ودارفور اللي هي
يعني قوات تعزيزيه الحميديه معنى ذلك انه
يعني الدعم السريع بيحتفظ بقوات كبيره جدا
في الاقاليم بالرغم انه يعني يعني لو
نلاحظ انه يعني الجيش قال انه المنطقه
الشماليه هو كلها تحت سيطرته شرق السودان
اللي هو في كسلان تحت سيطرته عن ابيض يعني
نوعا ما برضو فيها مشاكسات لانه هم امس
الوالي اعلن حظر التجول
فانا اعتقد انه
الخوف وليس اخشاه انه لو يعني حسم الجيش
المعركه في الخرطوم لما لم تكن له تعزيزات
قويه فانها تمر بشكل كبير في هذين
المنطقتين انا اعتقد الحرب سوف تسال يعني
هناك
انا الساحه العالميه تقول بان 16% فقط من
المرافق الصحيه تعمل في السودان كما نتابع
مشاهدينا اسفل الشاشه في هذا الخبر العاجل
هناك موضوع ايضا مهم كان قد تم تداوله
بالامس وهو هروب بعض القيادات نظام الرئيس
المعزول عمر البشير وهروبها كان هو ايضا
من ضمن من اذكروا بانه قد هرب من سجن كوبر
لكن الجيش اكد انه موجود في سجن العسكري
عندما يعني نسال عن مساله السجون
ومن هرب منها من بقي ايضا كذلك فيها هل
تنتظر السودان فوضى خلاقه كما يقال خلال
الفتره القادمه
لا تنتظر الان بدات الفوض تزيد الان الان
في سجلت بعض الجرائم والقتل والنهب في على
المنازل يعني المواطنين الان بيشتكوا انه
في ناس
احتيالات بشكل كبير جدا وطبعا هذول
المجرمين ومنهم محكوم عليهم بالاعدام
وممكن محكوم عليهم بجرائم سرقه خطيره جدا
وتزوير ومخدرات كل هذه فهذه يعني هذه
الفئات لمن تكون موجوده في الشوارع او
تطلق من السجون اعتقد انه معدل الجريمه
هيزداد وهذا سوف يؤثر على الحاله الامنيه
للمن سيستفيد من هذه الحاله
والله انا انا اعتقد الجيش ما مستفيد لكن
اعتقد انه في طرف انا انا ممكن ما اريد ان
يعني اصلح بان لكن اعتقد في الطرف الذي
ساعد في اطلاق هؤلاء السجناء هو الذي يريد
ان هو الذي يريد ان تكون هنا يشغل يشغل
طرف اخر
بهذه المساله انا نقطه لم يتبقى لديه شكرا
جزيلا لك شكرا جزيلا لكل من شاهدنا في هذه
الساعه زي طالب كنعان سيكمل معكم الساعه
القادمه في تغطيتنا لشان السوداني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات